hello everyone and welcome to another
wonderful game that never actually
happened it's more of a demonstration of
what will happen if you do uh certain
forbidden things in chess like grabbing
a poison pawn uh it's a mr hoodie guy
versus a random non-playable character
that's why i'm wearing the the really
big hoodie since we have two hoodie guys
hope you guys are doing that as well or
you can just wear two regular hoodies
that's also fine
and now uh it's um
not very long it's actually a
constructed game that lasts 12 moves but
in those 12 moves you guys will have to
pause the video moments and in those 12
moves you will learn a lot a lot of
theory about the the berlin defense if
you guys play it if you don't uh then
even better uh so let's dive straight
into it and see what this is all about
so uh mr hoodie guy opens with e4 and we
have e5 by mr npc uh going for a nice
symmetrical structure knight to f3
knight to c6 and bishop to b5 the rule
lopez is on the board and like we said
knight to f6 the berlin defense and
you've seen this many times in the world
on this channel pretty much everywhere
as it's uh well it's a favorite of many
top grand masters and it's very very
solid
we have castles by white knight captures
on e4 by mr npc this is the real gambit
accepted we have d4 and now if you uh
ever saw this position in a real game uh
where for example grandmasters are
playing uh knight the d6 will be played
like 99.9 percent of the times as this
is the strongest move recommended by the
engine uh players might also use bishop
to e7 or a6 if it's maybe an unserious
game if it's a blitz game or something
like that
and maybe try and uh throw white off
guard maybe get him out of his
preparation but knight to d6 is the
standard idea here however uh you
probably saw this uh a lot of times and
you you always wonder but what happens
if black just gets greedy and captures
this d4 pawn
well this is exactly what you will learn
in this video so if e captures on d4
which is a reply that you might
encounter online someone plays the
berlin defense here you offer this pawn
and they grab it so now you have to
punish black somehow uh so white will
play rook to e1 now you will uh you are
threatening to capture the knight and of
course the knight cannot move the knight
is pinned the king is on e8 uh d5
defending the knight and now okay
luckily you don't have a d3 pawn so you
don't win the knight
right away or rather black doesn't lose
a piece right away and here you want to
play knight captures on d4 and continue
your attack you will put a lot of
pressure on the c6 square and and so on
however queen captures on d4 is uh not
as strong as knight captures but it's
much much trickier and this is wha
one of the things that could happen and
why you guys suggested this for example
a6 now we attacked the bishop here and
now if the bishop moves for example
anywhere along this diagonal we can just
capture the queen so of course we can't
do that we have to capture on c6 so
bishop captures on c6 would check b
captures and now comes knight to g5 here
white is just going full barbarian mode
you could also just continue development
or go bishop to g5 but knight to g5 is
the tricky idea here that you guys will
enjoy the most and now
black needs to
play a nice developing move like bishop
to e6 and the game continues nothing out
of the ordinary happening here where
white will have the option of either
capturing an e6 or grabbing the e4
knight and then grabbing also the pawn
and putting pressure on c6 so it's equal
material
black has a
damaged pawn structure here it's a
double c pawn and an isolated a pawn but
black does have the bishop pair so all
in all white shouldn't really have
anything here uh however in this
constructed game uh queen to f6 was
played and it seems like a really good
idea uh we force a queen trailer we we
go into the end game and indeed if white
uh plays queen captures on f6 that will
be the case however uh white had
something else in mind here so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
absolute crushing move for white while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is knight captures on
e4 and that's the good stuff so
congratulations to everyone who spotted
this of course you all see that now uh
after knight captures on e4 black can
just resign the game is over and you see
that of course if the queen is captured
queen captures
queen on d4 we're gonna play knight to
f6 with check and this is now a double
check with a discovery from the rook on
e1 uh this is covered by the knight this
is covered by the knight this is covered
by the rope so the only square is king
to d8 and now of course we deliver rook
to e8 with checkmate so obviously the
queen cannot be accepted so if the queen
cannot be accepted after knight captures
an e4 our only option is d captures an
e4 in this constructed game that i
received the the game ended with this
checkmate queen captured on d4 and
that's it okay black guess check mated
but it's even nicer that even if black
plays d captures on e4 black is still
completely lost but it's not as easy to
spot as this um sort of a queen offering
because after queen captures an e4 with
check what does black play if you block
with the bishop then we simply capture
here on
on the c6 square uh if you play queen to
e6 that's also pretty bad just queen
captures in c6 check and now you just uh
resign as the queen is also pinned you
cannot capture so uh bishop to e7 can be
played and now there is one move that
again wins the game on the spot for
white which i think is even more
impressive than the one that we've seen
so again feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this crushing idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh deflecting the
queen from the defense of the c6 pawn
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is bishop to g5 that's
again that's just the good stuff and now
there is nothing black can do here if
you move the queen then we have a triple
attack on the bishop on e7 and we just
start grabbing material and of course if
the bishop is accepted now the queen no
longer guards the c6 pawn queen captures
on c6 and after king to d8 we just play
queen capture 78 and that's it now of
course white is completely winning uh
you're not just up in material but also
the bishop cannot move there's no way
for the rook to get into the game and
after a few moves are made let's say
bishop to d6 knights the c3 and let's
say queen h4 threatening checkmate we
simply kick away the queen and after
queen before rook d1 and that's it of
course black cannot survive this it's
only a matter of time before the
position just uh just crumbles so really
really impressive stuff and
i hope you guys hope you guys enjoyed
this one so if you play the berlin
defense remember after white plays this
d4 move the rio gambit accepted
variation never play e captures on d4 so
you have to play knight to d6 like the
grand masters do it's not just that they
are showing off it's actually the
strongest move so this is what you have
to play if you if you are a berlin
defense player and then you will have a
very very enjoyable game but if you
encounter e captures on d4 uh know that
you are on the verge of achieving a
great victory and your opponent did not
study the berlin properly or watch this
video
uh so yeah that's the the the construct
of the game hope you guys enjoyed it uh
two uh two shorter videos and i'm also
planning another shorter video uh before
the start of the big tournament tomorrow
is then we are going to cover uh that
tournament for for like uh maybe uh 10
days so uh you know a nice few relaxing
short ones uh so once again i hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
david kimura john gilfoyle dominique
novelli adam rosenberg and francis ayer
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day